on a scale of one to safe how safe is
this what we're doing not point-three
not that's not bad
better than what we usually get hello
it's a video again funnily enough it's
what we do it's all we do we all know
that liquids look great in slow-mo
flying through the air so looks awesome
don't it
you know that's better than that what's
that liquids on fire alright so we got
on the cards bit petrol in it and then a
tray and I'm gonna do this with a petrol
on fire obviously and what is our
contingency plan for to be inevitable
when the grass is entirely on fire a leg
is on fire and the grass we're not
intelligent enough to have a blanket so
we've got a hose we're just gonna really
pretty much do nothing
my legs the priority here but the grass
will try and save if we can but yeah
it's doubtful yeah it also has plenty of
bloody grass around yeah it's quite
moist
okay it's gonna go far so I'm gonna film
with the Phantom flex from a low angle
handheld stupid gofer that's cool you
could like a fireball I followed it
through the hands oh that's wicked
now you might be wondering why I love
this footage looks very dark that's
because the flames are brighter than the
current sky we have today if the Sun was
out it would be a bit better but
everything is exposed so the flames
don't look white compared to us that's
so clever thumbs up so what we gonna do
now Troy Robson that's burning through
the air mmm
hopefully won't get any on me I do then
I've got a will we've also got this as a
reference view of your face yeah so the
plastic setters can put it back on when
they find it might be a bit crispy bacon
but hopefully might not melted you're
like a my local pork scratching by the
time we're done the hair on my face will
go first yeah
smudging a little bit more beauty today
than usual I know a week off it beard
action going on it's always good always
good
Oh King
right sir I think we've oh I think we've
successfully proven that things look
really good flying for ya oh sorry
mother yeah they do look good
oh she's flat yeah not as safe as well
it's not safe don't try it home not that
what you should do is follow us on
please follow us on Twitter
here are our usernames mine is Gavin
free here is Daniel brushy
give those a click